Alright, well, hi everyone
I'm please today, I'm very pleased to
Have the opportunity, the privilege,
to speak with General Stanley McChrystal
General McChrystal retired in July 2010 as a four star general.
After over 34 years of service in the US army,
His final assignment was as the commander of NATO's
International Security Assistance Force
and all US forces in Afghanistan.
He had previously served as
the director of the Joint Staff
Yo, there's a, there's a research showing what makes a physician an effective diagnostician.
and one of the markers is the number of words that the patient speaks
compared to the number of words the physician speaks in the first 15 minutes of their interaction.
and the more words the patient speaks the higher the diagnostic accuracy of the physician.